something is going on on this planet
around the issue of biology something
has broken through here some kind of
higher-order organizational process is
in play that is larger than the human
species larger than the historical
damage we have done to the planet
something is going on and I think that
we are reaching the cultural stage where
if we can sufficiently decondition we
can understand what it is it's something
about the biological integrity of the
planet and cognition and ourselves as
instruments of something that wants to
manifest itself through the release of
energy and the control of matter in some
form I mean it's not clear whether we
are preparing to build spacecraft the
size of Manhattan that are going to go
off to the stars and win an empire along
the Milky Way and that is our destiny or
whether we can go inward and you know
place our entire world and a single
grain of sand and leave that grain of
sand on an Indonesian beach somewhere
and just retreat from the planet into
some other dimension that we will create
you know perhaps we can build a module
and bury it on the moon and then radio
transmitter ourselves into it's
interspecies and live in a simulacrum of
a real world forever as a penance for
what we did to the planet
the scenarios are endless because the
cultural dimension that opens ahead of
us is the imagination that's what all
this stuff is that's where all these
things are living we are going to be the
horrified witnesses of the revelation of
the true nature of the human soul we are
going to find out what everybody else
only wondered about which is who are we
really what will we do with ourselves
when we are freed from the constraints
of gravity energy and yes morality and
politics what are we when we begin to
take off our cultural clothing what kind
of world will we build in a pure
imagination
the engineering fantasies of those who
would build spacecraft the size of
Manhattan
hallo worlds with tilled fields and
swaths of rainforests and savanna in
their sides that is the first step the
imaging of the mother world to prove
that one cognizes the situation but
human beings are creatures of art and
whether this art is erected in massive
structures in orbit around Jupiter or
whether it is erected in some kind of
fractal and syntactical electronics
simulated space that is somehow quantum
mechanically sustained it doesn't matter
the point is the liniments of the
imagination the projection of human hope
and creativity there is a stirring in
the primates they feel the eerie
nearness of the thing and this eerie
of nearness of the other slowly acts as
a vector on the animal mind and points
it toward the transcendence and we begin
the quest we don't even know that we've
begun the quest but the disruption of
the unquestioning animal Piran nowness
is finished the 20th century model is
that life is a desert you know man has
been abandoned by God life is a desert
all ethics are provisional all values
are culture-bound just bom bom bom bom
wrapped this is the modern situation
everything is completely distance old
and dead and pointless and then you
discover you know that the mystery is a
right